hi i'm to you i will present the paper
domain specification of discrete
distribution using entropy independence
this is a joint work with my advisor
nima nari at stanford
mikhailski at university of michigan and
elizabeth young at university of
california berkeley
so we consider this
problem of sampling from the script
distribution given the discrete
distribution mu that means the
distribution over psi k subset of a
given graph set of size n we want to
sample or approximately sample for mu so
how much time do we need to
produce one sample for mu for general
mean we shouldn't expect to get faster
than n to the k time say if your muse is
four it does one element then it takes
like end of the k time to
find this single element in the support
also for approximately sample from ui
means like to sample from distribution
mu prime that is
close to mu in tb distance
so
um
we hope that for certain family of mu
after some pre-processing we can reduce
domain size that is the side the ground
set from n to some t much smaller than n
and consequently get improved runtime
for the sampling task
a a related problem is to count or
approximately tell plus some family
omega of psi k subset
of a ground set of size n
so by approximate car we we mean that i
put in uh h of z so that the size omega
between half z and
and
has the times one plus epsilon
so one way to do that is to repeatedly
approximately sample from the uniform
distribution over omega
and this follows from a classical result
of the roomba irani invariant in 1986
the more sample we get from mu the more
accurately we can count omega
since we need to produce many samples
from mu we want to reduce the amortized
time complexity of
sampling for mu after some preprocessing
step
um example distribution where the domain
specification uh has
been useful includes determinant of
prime processes uh uniform distribution
over a spanning tree of a fixed cipher
graph or fixed side matching internal
graph
so i will determine define determinants
of poi processors in the next slide but
here i just want to remind you of the
definition of matching tree and forest
of a graph so given the graph g a
spanning tree a set of edges that form a
connected and look this sub-graph of g
so here in this picture the orange edges
form a spanning tree of the graph
the definition for forest is similar but
we only require the subgraph to be
loopless but not necessarily connected
so if we take the spanning tree and
remove one of the orange edges then we
would obtain a forest
and a sanity also for itself by the way
and
so a k matching is a set of k edges
where no two edges share the same
endpoint so here um in this picture
the
orange edges form a two matching
um and also this uh this graph is also a
planar graph meaning that we can draw
this graph on the page without any
crossing edges
so kd
kde sentimental point process
is the fiber matrix l and the
probability of a psi k subset as i
proportional to the minor of the sub
matrix l index by s here we have an
example where x is a set 1 2 and 4
and probability of this set is
proportional to the determinant of the
submatrix color in red here
usually we assume all principle minor of
l are non-negative so if additionally l
is symmetric then this means every
symmetric positive semi-definite and can
be written as the product of v and v
transpose
for some matrix v and in this case the
probability of a set as if proportional
to the volume of the space spanned by
the vectors indexed by s and the vector
is defined by v here
so for example the uniform distribution
over standard device graph g
is also a symmetric dpp with l equal v
times v transpose and vb in the incident
matrix of g
for lbp the traditional focus e on
semantic matrix is l but a live reason
worked by gaffrell and other people
consider non-symmetric
matrix l for its enhanced modeling power
mode symmetric and non-symmetric dpp has
many applications in a wide variety of
field including in machine learning such
as in recommended system and image
search and also in randomized linear
entrepreneur you can refer to the many
papers up within water because they are
tasker varun berezinski and other people
to learn about the definition of
symmetric and non-symmetric dbp
and the application
so i will mention a bright history of
the domain classification framework
so this live work study with
work by luffy people's pain and route in
2017 where they use a similar domain
specification idea to cal spending tree
in graph in quality time
morrison's work include exact sampling
of symmetric determinant of poi
processors by deriving in codes 19 and
then by calendar yellow rohinski and
ranco in nearly 19 and 20.
um so
and then the first paper last year by
nema and mikhail nadinski get a similar
result on log concave distribution uh we
include uh symmetric determinant of pi
processes so this paper will only apply
to distribution that satisfy log
concavity a very strong assumption would
roughly mean that the hypergraph
associating with the distribution is a
very strong high dimensional expander
we'll obtain the
generalization of nema and becomes a fox
paper for multi-water classical
distribution would include non-symmetric
dpp and distribution over fixed imaging
as well at all distribution considered
in the previous work
so the distribution all found the class
of endothelially independent
distribution
and the notion of entropy independence
were recently introduced by nema myself
and other co-authors and turned out to
be the right assumption for the domain
specifications team to work
so we will
go on a detour briefly and talk a little
bit about something from continued
distribution to get
some ideas for our case so there's this
framework for something from continual
distribution where you can sample from a
continuous distribution whole density
function e
molar concave and then f um is also in
an isotropic position
so for
continuous distribution over the
dimensional vector space
uh
fb in in the attribute position mean
that the mean of f is um
is the zero vector
the the the mean of the of the vector
um
uh
taken according to the receiving device
the f is a zero vector and the covariant
matrix is the identity
also for continuous distribution that
has log concave density but not in
energy position we can do a
transformation like
scaling or shifting the domain to put it
in an attribute position
anari rinsky
force paper last year so that we can
obtain an anonymous framework for
discrete distribution
so i already linsky say that the
discrete distribution mu
is isotopic if the marginal of each
element are roughly the same
where the marginal element i is defined
the probability of i being included in
the set x when we sample s for mu
so there is a very simple procedure that
converts any distribution to an
energetic
distribution the way it works is suppose
we know the material of the element
um
so here we have the element from one to
n with the blue column we know the
dimethyl
and
the higher the marginal is the taller
the blue column is so we see that six
had a very high marginal so the natural
ide maybe we can split six into many
smaller copy and now each smaller copy
will have roughly the same material the
thing is this operation as i spit in
splitting the column into many smaller
squares of the same size
so the next question is of course how
can we compute the materials for
determinant of y processes this
equivalent to some linear product can be
done quite efficiently
and generally we can compute the
marginal by
uh sampling then use the
capital sampling reduction
of
irani
there's also more delicate
handling process than getting done
faster for special class distribution
and for that you can look at me calling
nima's host paper
but here our paper also improve upon
previous work in the pre-processing step
because we only need to estimate the
marginal within a constant faster
whereas previous work need to either
compute the marginal exactly or estimate
the metronome within in both polynomial
precision but i won't go into the
technical detail here
okay so assume we need this anitropic
information so how can we use entropy to
accelerate something
so here we have a very
simple idea of intermediate sampling so
we take a subset t of element of the
domain
and then we sample from b residue to t
then instantly you reduce the test of
sampling from side n domain to psi t
domain
the problem is this doesn't quite work
so for many distribution of interest we
need the to set the size
of the set t to be huge in order to get
anything that is officially close to the
target distribution mu
okay so
this is nice well it doesn't work so how
can we fix this
so
we will repeat this process a few times
so we start
s0 we sample some s t or row
uh uniformly at random and then we add
it to s0
then
we now sample to get a new set s1 and
then we repeat the process with x0
replace by s1
so we repeat the process of fuel time
and the gain is that we can get inverse
polynomially close to the tiny
distribution mu by repeating the process
uh only log many steps
and this is a nice thing about the
multi-color chain uh the the about the
monte carlo markup chain method
so
uh and then
also each step of this intermediate
sampling markov chain can be implemented
efficiently using the
local random works introduced in
previous work
by
ali muhammadi nima
kiran kumar zirago and and i
in stock this year
okay so
um so we
need to
but to learn like how how small can we
make the
side the set be
so let's get some intuition
so consider this distribution mu
um
on subset of side 2 of the
set of the vertices
that is defined by a bypass graph g
so mu the uniform distribution over the
edges of g
so consider a
random subset t of the vertices
for there to even be one edges contained
in t with non-negligible probability we
need to have side roughly
root n by the birthday paradox
okay so on the right is the
bypass graph
and more generally for distribution on
subset of psi k we need t to be at least
n raised to 1 minus 1 over k to get even
a single object in the support of the
distribution
so for those who see that consider the
the case when mu and colon hypergraph
where each hyperedge contain
capabilities in a similar fashion to the
mu in the previous slide that encode a
bipartite like
general graph like normal graph
then
now the question is
okay so it seems we can get from
a set domain of side n to the minus sign
n raised to 1 minus 1 over k but can we
do better than that can we get t to be
some sub linear function of n
that whose exponent doesn't depend on k
for example say t equal to n raised to
0.9
and the answer is that we can for many
distribution of interest
and we will formally define
the class of such distribution next
so we we will define entropy dependence
and we begin by defining the generating
polynomial of the squared distribution
so for distribution mu let it generating
polynomial f mu b is the multiplied a
polynomial on variable d1 to zn
that is defined as the sum of mu of s
times
the product of c i for r in s
and
here we can think of f mu as
a tension of the
density function mu
supported on the squished subset to the
entire real space r to the n
so now finally we are really ready to
define entropy independence
a distribution mu is entropically
independent if the
uh transformation of the challenging
polynomial is valid above by its tangent
at the point
z1 to zn equal r1
so here the transformation is defined
like this and this pi which is the
marginal of the element i divided by k
is actually also the
for derivative of f mu s z i
and
and uh where all the z one to the n are
set to one
so this definition was introduced by
nima myself
and
vishal fred and hui in the paper this
year there's also an equivalent
definition in terms of the entropy
conduction of a certain operator called
the now operator
the sender setup site came to a set of
size one by selecting an element
uniformly at random
but we only need the first definition
for this talk
for further explanation about entropy
independence please refer to the talk i
gave at eth
with the video recording on youtube
so the intuition number enterprise
independence is the higher the parameter
amphis the stronger the entropy
independence assumption
so this means that if a distribution is
endocrine independence with parameter
alpha and also that is also entropically
independent for all parameters alpha
prime less than alpha
um
so one thing
that is nice that all distribution
of over sets of psi k uh actually
integrally uh actually entropically
independent with alpha at least one over
k
and you can prove this using cautious
wars
some example of entropy independent with
a higher parameter alpha
especially with amphibian that is the
constant include the
spanning tree distribution the uh
symmetric and non-symmetric determinant
of
processes and
the
distribution related to k markings in
graph
and the the last one i want to make here
is that the isotropic transformation
scheme we discussed earlier preserve
entropy independence
so
we can as well as make will assume that
our distribution is both entropy
independence and other topic
so now we are ready to start our main
result we saw that for one novel alpha
and the quickly independent mu we can
reduce the test of something from a
distribution over domains of side n to a
distribution over domain of size n
raised to one minus alpha
times some poly k
um
so application of the multi-room include
fast algorithm to cause a cycai matching
in
implanograph
and also has the algorithm two sample
from non-semantic and symmetric dpp
also for results also that for all
distribution after some pre-processing
we can always reduce the domain side
from n to n raised to one minus one over
k and this matches the multiply parallel
test hole
in the example that i talked in the
hypergraph example that i talked about
earlier
so we discussed some high level um
so we we also saw that the domain side
we obtained is high for entropy
independent distribution in terms of the
dependency on and the lower bar
construction we have here is made on
risk terminal code our logo about still
apply even if our pre-processing steps
allow access to higher order marginal
view
we
next we discuss some high-level ideas of
the proof we will show that in one step
the intermediate sampling markov chain
we get within constant distance of the
design distribution mu that means after
apply one step of the markov chain
starting from any set s0
we get a set s1 whole distribution is
within 0.1
of mu in terms of t resistance
then this will imply that for any
epsilon we can get within x log of mu in
log of 1 over epsilon step
so
if x long is inverse a polynomial in n
we can get like within epsilon of mu in
log n step
so okay so now our test is only to prove
this
inequality
um so after some transformation and
change and inequality we can lower about
this ratio by
this
expectation
formula
uh raised to the
power of one minus one
and now we can we want to up about this
this especially in star
and the nice thing about it especially
that we can rewrite in term of the
trinity polynomial of mu
and now we can apply the entropy
independence definition to up about this
polynomial by the time turn but it's
titan at the point on one and then
because the titan at the point on one is
related to the
marginal of each element and we know
that the marginal element is roughly one
over n because of the isotopic uh
assumption so
we can bow this entire expression and
and then by choosing a suitable t around
n to the one minus alpha where we are
done
so to conclude the main classification
is a useful scheme to produce many
samples from a distribution in faster
amortized time so this in turn reduce
the time complexity of many counting
problems the until the classic
approximate sampling to cardiac
reduction including the problem of
parting k matching implanocraft or
calcium cycle forest and so on so our
work will generalize the the main
specification framework considered in
uh andrey nezinski's uh fox paper
the remaining open problem is whether we
can reduce the domain side to be
independent of n we know that it is true
for symmetric epp and distribution over
base of plane k matrix through previous
work we contracted that this is also
true for k matching and non-symmetric
dpp and more generally for all amphi
partially log concave distribution if we
allow a preprocessing step where we are
given assets to higher order marginals
so that is the end of my talk thank you